new york post
usa today demoted me for a tweet because
it's woke newsrooms are out of touch
with readers
check this out i was usa today's i'm i'm
gonna skim i was usa today's deputy
editorial page editor until august when
i was demoted after i tweeted quote
people who are pregnant are also women
can you imagine
that idea was forbidden because a news
reporter covering diversity equity and
inclusion wrote a story detailing how
transgender men can get pregnant they
can i compounded my sin against this new
orthodoxy by calling the idea that men
can get pregnant and
opinion wasn't allowed to say that that
was an opinion had to be fact
had to be fact
if i wanted to keep my job or any job at
usa today my bosses informed me i needed
to delete those offensive tweets because
they were crossing pain to the lgbtq
activists and journalists on our staff
and this this is the best line i've been
an opinion journalist for 30 years i
thought i was authorized to have
opinions no
you're not
you're not anymore so this is where
we're at now you understand how this
slippery slope i always say the slippery
slope is like slip and slide now i don't
even know if that suffices because
sometimes the slip and slide i'd get on
there and i wouldn't slide
this is like a water slide that's like
straight up and down
and there's no room to even catch up
people are like wait a minute what i
can't just say that that's an opinion
i can't say there's a difference between
a man and a woman
biologically what i can't criticize the
idea of puberty blockers and children
why
the silencing
that's why
and that's why i started out with a
conversation on groupthink and now
you're getting here because i'm trying
to show that what we're doing here
is really really sick and sinister when
it comes to silencing people who see the
world differently or have questions or
in some cases who are just stating facts
right
the fact that there are biological men
and biological women that's a fact it's
a fact you don't have to like it
you could be like i don't like that fact
you know what i don't like a lot of
facts i don't like the fact that it's
human in florida do you see my hair do i
need to bring attention to it again
tyler's like please jed minimize
attention people won't notice if you
just shh
i don't like that but it's not gonna i'm
not gonna say i don't like it walk
outside and it's going to feel like
massachusetts air no it's florida
it's florida
and it's funny i had a conversation with
a very gay friend of mine
very young very young yesterday i called
him and i said listen i need to talk to
you he said what he's like you want me
to come visit
i said maybe
but also
i said
am i missing something here
with the gender tell me the truth am i
being insensitive or am i missing
something and he said to me these were
his words
no
he said i'm not attracted to women
i'm attracted to men
women and men are different i'm not
attracted to women
i'm not attracted to women dressed as
men i'm attracted to men
they're different
and he just said it like that
and i just you know i legitimately
called because i was like wait a minute
you know am i am i missing something
where
in the same way that i asked you know
with the the trump stolen election i'm
like tell tell me what it is and i would
sit here and have a conversation with
someone who sees this issue very
differently too but we have to be able
to at least acknowledge that biological
men and women exist right there has to
be some we can't talk about the fact
that oh planet earth let's make it
better if we don't acknowledge it's a
planet right there's got to be some
thread of just fact
that underlies all of this right
apparently not
apparently not
sanity is turning into madness and
madness is getting glorified and sanity
is getting silenced
that's what's happening
how many genders do you think there are
just think about them and it's a
rhetorical question
rhetorical question i'm asking the
people at home how many genders you
might say two maybe somebody said four
well no you're all wrong tyler i'm here
to tell you jorge too everyone's wrong
in fact there are more than 150 genders
okay 150 telegraph
let's take a look
bbc staff
told there are more than 150 genders and
their urge to develop a trans brand
the telegraph has obtained material
provided to radio staff by global
butterflies a transgender group that the
bbc drafted in for training sessions
last summer and autumn
emails were sent to radio producers and
program editors some from heads of
departments urging them to attend the
training during the sessions leaked to
the telegraph staff were shown an array
of gender-neutral pronouns they should
be using including z zem and zers
okay
and we're told people can self-identify
themselves in over 150 ways and
increasing soon it could be 500.
staff were told they should include
their pronouns in email signature boxes
to be part of your trans brand
as an inclusive and welcoming brilliant
show
of ally support
so not only do you need to not laugh
hysterically when somebody says 100 come
on 150 genders
i'm supposed to swallow that
really i'm supposed to sit here swallow
that and just say okay that's well
that's the basis of a factual
conversation now let's come on
150 genders
that's fantasy here we are again in the
land of oz
not only that though the last part is
the best part you too
should sign
with your pronouns in the email
because you have to show solidarity
so if you don't sign with your pronouns
because you're like well i'm a girl i'm
female what why'd i have to what why
don't i tell everybody that like
and also why do i need to put that in my
huh maybe that's you
not good enough you have to do it
because that showcases that you are part
of the cause
you're part of the cause and if you're
not part of the cause
maybe you don't keep your job
maybe you don't i'm not saying the
telegraph's gonna fire people i'm saying
it happens in places
maybe you don't keep your job
maybe you're ostracized oh did you get
that email she didn't put her prone out
she she doesn't she's she's not one of
us
she doesn't believe in the cause
she's a big she's a homophobe she's
anti-trans
i mean they'll come up with i don't even
know how many words i don't even know
can you say anti-trans or is trans not a
thing now is there a better word for it
i feel like i'm gonna wake up tomorrow
it's gonna be a better word you're not
gonna be able to say trans anymore
i had a friend went to uh
gay pride parade in new york gay guy
he called me he said
i'm not cool enough for this parade so
like wasn't this about the gays at one
point
said like everything was like trans and
if you weren't talking trans you were
outdated he fell out he's like i feel
outdated
very gay very gay always went to pride
so
again
think about what's happening
the slippery slope got slipperier
maybe maybe you haven't changed your
mind about that issue but now the
expectation is that you will
if you don't tow the new line to maximum
capacity by the way not even just saying
hey i don't care what you call yourself
like but i don't
i just don't need to put my pronoun like
i don't want to nope
x
scarlet letter
and
now you're gonna have a bunch of friends
who get upset because you're not putting
the pronouns i actually had people upset
with me because i have a tweet i wrote
the other day i don't know if you saw
this i said if you have pronouns in your
i don't remember exactly what i said but
it was like if you have pronouns in your
bios i can't take
i can't take anything else you say
seriously i meant it
i meant it because it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous you can call yourself
whatever you want but if you have
pronouns in your bio that tells me that
a you just
biology cease to matter to you you just
don't i mean we're just going to throw
that away biology doesn't matter or
you're so desperate to be included in
some woke cause that you now even though
you're not trans even though your life
doesn't involve that at all even though
it doesn't affect you whatsoever you
need to put that stamp on your twitter
to be like i'm part of the club don't
excommunicate me c
sticker
facts boosted
he him
i can't i just i can't have respect for
people who do that
it's hard it's very hard for me i'd love
to have a conversation with people who
feel it's important to put those things
in let's sit down and talk about it but
it's very hard for me to take things
seriously when people are so desperate
the reason is if you're so desperate to
be part of that cause you'll say
anything you'll say anything
oh i need to say that
you know
people actually walk on all fours no
actually we don't but i'm walking on two
legs no no you're walking on all fours
you're walking on all fours that's what
i was told to say all fours hashtag all
fours really it's getting ridiculous
it's getting ridiculous
and i'm tired of being lectured i really
am i'm tired it even would have been
fine to me with you do your pronouns do
whatever you got to do but when it
became about what i need to you're
telling me what i need to do no that's
not going to work
so here's my invitation to all of you
don't allow yourself to be silenced
do not allow yourself to be silenced i
don't care
what that entails
okay
you may lose a job
and by the way i don't mean you know
start screaming at everybody and saying
horrible thing don't insult people you
know be respectful
obviously
in your discourse but what i'm saying is
you have an opinion you have a right to
say it i know so many people in new york
city
that refused they were like oh my god
i'm opposed to these mandates i didn't
get the vaccine but i would never say it
they were terrified that they would lose
business they were terrified they'd be
ostracized so you know what happened
they wound up having they were silent
zipped up
little zippers you never see those
characters little zippers on the mouth
can't open it up until somebody says
it's okay
and they had to sit and listen
to somebody else and i remember remember
the vaccine is amazing dr fauci oh my
god he's the best thing since sliced
wood he knows exactly what he's doing
even though he's taking two rounds of
drugs and now had four shots and still
got covered they have to listen to all
of this
constantly so it's like a one-way show
right one group of people has freedom
and the other are silence because
they're afraid don't be afraid you
cannot be afraid because if you allow
yourself to be afraid to speak your mind
then the people who want to control what
everybody says when
okay and i this is not left right i
don't care where you stand
you're left winger listening to this you
believe in big government speak your
mind
speak your mind
you're a right-winger you believe in
limited government speak your mind you
believe in the pronoun whatever speak
your speak your mind if you're one of
the people out there who believe that
other people should have a voice even
when they disagree with you speak your
mind we need you even if you disagree
with me we need you
we need you our kids need you
out there speaking for them if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]